programming throwdown episode 62 php and hack take it away jason hey everyone uh welcome back first uh podcast of the year year unless you're on the Chinese New Year and I think this is like nearing the end of your year right is that true I think yes I think it starts like next week oh really oh well depends on when this is released oh yeah good point t-shirt um january 28th beginning of the year oh interest says yeah this will this may be the beginning of the year for for everybody uh for all for both calendars of which i'm fully aware um so we have our t-shirt winners uh josh p and sam are uh two patreon subscribers that I drew at random. And actually, this is kind of, I don't know, funny or sad or whatever.
Programming Throwdown 第62期：PHP 和 Hack，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，欢迎回来。这是今年的第一个播客，除非你是在过中国农历新年，我想这应该快到你们年底了，对吧？我想是的，我想大概下周开始。哦，真的吗？好吧，这取决于这期节目什么时候发布。哦，对，好观点。T恤，1月28日，年初。哦，有趣，是的，这可能是每个人的年初，对于两个日历来说都是如此，我完全了解。所以我们有我们的T恤获奖者，Josh P. 和 Sam R.，他们是我随机抽取的两位 Patreon 订阅者。实际上，这有点，我不知道，好笑还是悲哀，或者随便什么。
I was going to use the Patreon API and write a Python script and do all this stuff. And then I realized Patreon just lets me download a CSV with all the names and email addresses of people who have subscribed. So I put that CSV into Excel and then addresses of people who have subscribed. So I put that CSV into Excel, and then I just randomized the rows. After telling everyone I was going to learn the Patreon API, it turns out I didn't even have to do that. I used trusty-dusty Excel. But yeah, after that random function, Josh P. and Sam R. were at the top of the list,
我本来打算使用 Patreon API 并编写一个 Python 脚本来做所有这些事情。然后我意识到 Patreon 只是让我下载一个包含所有订阅者姓名和电子邮件地址的 CSV 文件。所以我把那个 CSV 文件放进 Excel 里，然后我就随机排列了这些行。在告诉大家我要学习 Patreon API 之后，结果我甚至不需要那样做。我用了可靠的 Excel。但是，是的，在那个随机函数之后，Josh P. 和 Sam R. 排在了列表的最前面，
and they both will be getting some pretty epic t-shirts. I'm probably going to send them out later on this week, this week being the week we record. So by the time you listen to this, I would have already sent out the shirts. But congrats to you two, and I hope you really like your shirts. And thank you to all of our patreon subscribers and to all of our listeners whether or not you support us we thank you yeah definitely and we'll probably do this again i don't know really the cadence or things like that but uh we'll definitely do this again and and do more giveaways like this so uh thank you for subscribing following us uh you know getting uh following
他们俩都会得到一些非常棒的T恤。我可能会在本周晚些时候把它们寄出去，本周就是我们录制节目的这一周。所以当你听到这个节目时，我已经把T恤寄出去了。但恭喜你们两位，希望你们真的喜欢你们的T恤。也感谢我们所有的 Patreon 订阅者和我们所有的听众，无论你们是否支持我们，我们都感谢你们。是的，绝对的，我们可能会再做一次，我不知道具体的节奏或类似的事情，但我们肯定会再做一次，并进行更多这样的赠品活动。所以，感谢你们的订阅、关注我们，你知道，关注
our link to audible uh checking out the books we recommend and things like that that's really sort of what keeps sort of the whole show and all the expenses covered and keeps kind of everything together and if you're interested in a t-shirt uh there's a link to it on programmingthrowdown.com on where you can get those that's right it's pretty cool there's a regular t-shirt and there's a ringer T-shirt, which are those are actually my favorite. The ringer T-shirts are the ones where the you know, what do you call it? The end of the sleeve like that. Cuff. I guess that ring.
我们的 Audible 链接，查看我们推荐的书籍等等，这确实是维持整个节目并覆盖所有开支并把一切整合在一起的东西。如果你对T恤感兴趣，programmingthrowdown.com 上有一个链接，你可以在那里买到。没错，这很酷，有一件普通T恤和一件插肩袖T恤，那其实是我的最爱。插肩袖T恤就是那种，你知道，你叫它什么来着？袖口那样的。袖口。我想那是环状的。
Yeah. The sleeve cuff is like kind of like a thicker material and a different color. So it kind of like grabs your arm. I don't know. I kind of like those shirts. But yeah, they're both available. And I think there's even a hoodie available if you're interested in that.
对。袖口是一种比较厚的材料，颜色也不一样。所以它有点像抓住了你的手臂。我不知道。我挺喜欢那些T恤的。但是，是的，它们都有货。而且我想如果你感兴趣的话，甚至还有一件连帽衫。
Well, I want to rant about online television. All right. I feel this is one of those things we can talk about. And then five years from now, then we'll look back and realize how crazy it was when this was a problem, like whether or not to buy a smartphone or other classic examples. And this is, I don't have very good reception in my house. So I try to put up an antenna. It doesn't work. Cable's too expensive.
好吧，我想吐槽一下网络电视。好的。我觉得这是我们可以谈论的事情之一。五年后，我们会回过头来意识到当这是一个问题时是多么疯狂，就像是否要购买智能手机或其他经典例子一样。而且，我房子的信号不太好。所以我试着装一个天线。它不起作用。有线电视太贵了。
I don't, maybe that's just me being cheap, but I feel like for how much value I get out of it, actually paying for the normal cable subscription, they want to add all this extra stuff and it's too expensive. But I have been happy. Yeah, I agree, totally. Okay, yeah. And this is increasingly common from what I understand. I think lots of people are cutting cable.
我不知道，也许只是我太抠门了，但我觉得就我从中获得的价值而言，实际上支付正常的有线电视订阅费，他们想增加所有这些额外的东西，而且太贵了。但我一直很开心。是的，我完全同意。好的，是的。据我所知，这种情况越来越普遍。我想很多人都在取消有线电视。
But there's a lot of services, Sling TV, the PlayStation View, in America at least. And now there's like a direct TV one. But one of the issues is there's still all these weird things that happen. We wanted to watch, my wife and I wanted to watch the Golden Globes
但是有很多服务，Sling TV，PlayStation Vue，至少在美国是这样。现在还有一个 DirecTV 的。但问题之一是仍然会发生所有这些奇怪的事情。我们想看，我和我妻子想看金球奖
on Sunday night. And we just assumed it would be on the PlayStation View, which is the one we currently use. And we the guide said it was going to come on i could set it to be recorded we sat down and then it was you know just a kind of a message screen saying the rights to this are blocked by the network and it was like no really yeah so apparently even though in kind of every other way our subscription acts kind of like a cable subscription.
在周日晚上。我们只是假设它会在 PlayStation Vue 上，这是我们目前使用的那个。指南上说它会播出，我可以把它设置为录制，我们坐下来，然后，你知道，只是一个消息屏幕，说这个节目的版权被网络屏蔽了，就像，不是吧，真的吗？是的，所以显然，尽管在其他方面我们的订阅有点像有线电视订阅。
There was some rights conflict between NBC and the kind of Golden Globes themselves about online streaming permissions. And there was basically no legal way to stream the Golden Globes online. This is like a huge mess i mean i have this problem with the olympics where it's it's i feel like it actually i think we talked about this last olympics we talked about how this olympics would be totally on the internet and then that didn't happen but um i feel like every olympics and and this is true for the world cup as well the rules are different like the technology seems to be the same and we could have streamed even eight or twelve years ago the olympics but but the policy is completely different like i think two olympics ago you could see everything
NBC 和金球奖本身之间关于在线流媒体权限存在一些权利冲突。基本上没有合法的方式可以在线观看金球奖。这简直是一团糟，我的意思是，我在奥运会上也遇到过这个问题，我觉得，实际上我想我们上次奥运会谈过这个，我们谈到这次奥运会会完全在互联网上播出，但那并没有发生。但是，我觉得每一届奥运会，世界杯也是如此，规则都不一样，就像技术似乎是一样的，我们甚至在八或十二年前就可以直播奥运会了，但政策完全不同。就像我想两届奥运会前你可以看到一切，
and then the last olympics they had kind of highlights and i think this olympics is the same as the last one where you could get highlights but if you want to you know just watch it as if it was a tv station you had to have cable it's just kind of I don't know I feel like this is just like a house of cards you know basically you know they've built up all of these different policies around when you could show and how you can show and the advertisers you know what they get and what they don't get and what your commitment to them. And all it takes is really someone just kind of cracking this egg, like someone just getting a deal with the NBA, the NFL and a few other networks. And the whole thing will just fall apart. I don't know that that will happen, though, because one of the issues is they negotiate really long contracts
然后上一届奥运会他们只有一些集锦，我想这一届奥运会和上一届一样，你可以看到集锦，但如果你想，你知道，就像看电视台一样看它，你必须有有线电视。这只是，我不知道，我觉得这就像纸牌屋，你知道，基本上，你知道，他们围绕着你什么时候可以播放、怎么播放、广告商得到什么、得不到什么以及你对他们的承诺，建立了所有这些不同的政策。而所需要的真的只是有人打破这个蛋，就像有人和 NBA、NFL 以及其他几个网络达成协议。整个事情就会分崩离析。我不知道这是否会发生，因为问题之一是他们协商了非常长的合同，
and so i think part of the issue is like some of these it's like for the next five or ten years and so those contracts may or may not talk about streaming streaming will change dramatically in five years and they don't come up at the same time and then also i think there's other issues in our consideration but but for me it's just I'm pretty happy with my I first I had um the sling tv that was pretty good I actually like the playstation view much better this isn't a pitch for them I don't get paid by them I wish you had the roku at one point right I still now I'm using the amazon fire tv I think that one's pretty good but I did did have a Roku before. Yeah. And it works really well.
所以我认为部分问题在于，其中一些合同是未来五到十年的，所以这些合同可能会也可能不会谈到流媒体，流媒体在五年内会发生巨大变化，而且它们不会在同一时间到期。然后我也认为我们的考虑中还有其他问题，但对我来说，我对自己现在的服务很满意。起初我有 Sling TV，那还不错。我实际上更喜欢 PlayStation Vue，这不是在为他们做广告，我没有从他们那里拿钱。我记得你曾经有一个 Roku，对吧？我现在还在用 Amazon Fire TV，我觉得那个挺好的，但我之前确实有一个 Roku。是的。而且它工作得很好。
I really like it. But then you run into these weird things like what happened. I should have been able to watch it. I was at the right time. It wasn't even an issue of recording it or not recording it. But there was just no way for me to watch it. And that was really frustrating. You know, I wonder like, I mean, so Golden Globes. So this is this is gonna sound terrible but i don't even know what the golden globes are i think it's for the best movies right oh no that's the oscars
我真的很喜欢它。但随后你会遇到这些奇怪的事情，就像发生的那样。我本应该能看到它的。我在正确的时间。这甚至不是录制或不录制的问题。但就是没有办法让我看到它。这真的很令人沮丧。你知道，我想，我的意思是，金球奖。这听起来很糟糕，但我甚至不知道金球奖是什么。我想那是为了最好的电影，对吧？哦，不，那是奥斯卡。
no it's similar yeah similar and this isn't a pitch i actually don't care that much about the golden globes it was more just like we'd seen some stuff about it we weren't there was nothing else we were planning on watching and it's just something was like oh well let's sit down and watch that and then when you couldn't it was like oh now i'm bummed yeah right it's a forbidden fruit now right yeah but i didn't even care that much about it like if i had just known i wouldn't be able to stream it i wouldn't have cared i've started you know i have a bunch of youtube uh subscriptions and that's just become my sorts of entertainment, like YouTube and various kind of funny, you know, pages on Facebook and the funny subreddit on Reddit. I just, you know,
不，它很相似，是的，很相似。这不是在做广告，我其实并不太关心金球奖，这更多是因为我们看过一些关于它的东西，我们没有其他计划要看的东西，这只是像，哦，好吧，让我们坐下来看看那个。然后当你不能看的时候，就像，哦，现在我很沮丧。是的，没错，现在它是禁果了，对吧？是的，但我甚至没那么关心它。如果我早知道我无法流媒体播放它，我就不会关心了。我已经开始，你知道，我有一堆 YouTube 订阅，那已经成为我的娱乐方式，比如 YouTube 和 Facebook 上各种有趣的页面，以及 Reddit 上有趣的 subreddit。我只是，你知道，
I mean, to be fair, I didn't grow up with television. I actually never had cable TV until I met my wife and we moved in together. So my parents just never really had it. And so for me, it's not that unnatural to just be completely oblivious, like almost anything TV related, even really movies. I actually only recently saw the Star Wars, like the original movies.
我的意思是，公平地说，我不是看着电视长大的。我实际上在遇到我妻子并搬到一起住之前从来没有过有线电视。所以我父母从来没有真正拥有过它。所以对我来说，完全不知道电视相关的东西，甚至电影，并不是那么不自然。我其实直到最近才看了《星球大战》，比如最初的那些电影。
And so for me, it's all just youtube and internet and i feel as if that's just going to become more and more popular and eventually like even if the contracts are are for a long period of time just the economics will collapse but maybe that's not true i mean maybe our people are just really set i know for like sports for example you know the nfl channel is always going to be popular like nothing's going to know the nfl channel is always going to be popular like nothing's gonna change that you know they're not going to make a new set of teams or anything and a youtube only nfl yeah could you imagine i mean it's i guess it's totally possible right there's nothing well the problem is you need to build the stadiums right i don't know and some people say the
所以对我来说，一切都只是 YouTube 和互联网，我觉得这会变得越来越流行，最终，即使合同期限很长，经济也会崩溃。但也许那不是真的，我的意思是，也许人们只是非常固执。我知道比如体育运动，你知道，NFL 频道总是会很受欢迎，没什么会，你知道，NFL 频道总是会很受欢迎，没什么会改变这一点。你知道，他们不会组建一套新的球队什么的，而一个纯 YouTube 的 NFL，是的，你能想象吗？我的意思是，我想这完全有可能，对吧？没什么，好吧，问题是你需要建造体育场，对吧？我不知道，有些人说
e-gaming or e-sports but i just find those to be complicated in a way that isn't enjoyable in the same and i'm not a big sports fan but when i sit down and try to watch like streaming league of legends on twitch it just confuses me oh yeah i actually like um there's people who play games on Twitch and they just kind of tell jokes and just like they have raffles for prizes and stuff while they're playing. And I find that to be like pretty good background noise. OK, yeah, that could be interesting, like a person. But I mean, like watching the tournaments, I guess I don't play football, but I understand watching football and I understand the game. Maybe just because I always have. But like sitting down and watching league of legends yeah i think we've talked about that before but yeah it just seems so fast moving and fast paced it it just seems it isn't really
电子竞技，但我发现那些以一种不令人愉快的方式变得复杂，而且我不是一个大的体育迷，但当我坐下来尝试在 Twitch 上观看英雄联盟直播时，它只是让我感到困惑。哦，是的，我其实喜欢，嗯，有人在 Twitch 上玩游戏，他们只是讲笑话，就像他们在玩的时候为奖品抽奖什么的。我发现这作为背景噪音相当不错。好的，是的，那可能很有趣，就像一个人。但我的意思是，比如观看比赛，我想我不踢足球，但我理解看足球，我理解比赛。也许只是因为我一直都是这样。但像坐下来看英雄联盟，是的，我想我们之前谈过这个，但是的，它看起来太快了，节奏太快了，它似乎并不真正
conducive to sitting back and just watching yeah i think the problem with these games is you can't like zooming out doesn't really work like like football it works because you're zoomed out like if i was on the field i wouldn't be able to see everything would be just a blur and they're moving so fast and they're so strong like i was blown away i actually got an opportunity to go to levi stadium which people don't know that's the where the san francisco 49ers play well where the san francisco 49ers lose actually again i don't follow but i i heard that they're they did really like the worst team in the league but yeah um but yeah actually i got to go on the field which is really cool um but i had no idea like how big it is and it's one of these things like okay you know it's 100 yards
适合坐下来观看。是的，我认为这些游戏的问题在于你不能像，缩小画面并没有真正起作用。就像足球，它起作用是因为你缩小了画面。如果我在球场上，我就无法看到一切，那只会是一片模糊，而且他们移动得太快了，他们太强壮了。就像我被震撼了，我实际上有机会去李维斯体育场，人们不知道那是旧金山 49 人队比赛的地方，好吧，实际上是旧金山 49 人队输球的地方。再说一次，我不关注，但我听说他们是联盟中最差的球队，但是的，嗯，但实际上我得以进入球场，这真的很酷，嗯，但我不知道它有多大，这是其中之一，就像，好吧，你知道，它是 100 码，
it's very obvious but like unless you really go on the field it doesn't really make sense like you're you know like the idea that like these players they get tackled and sometimes they fall four yards I mean it's like an insane it's 12 feet like the person someone fell like two heights of a person in length, right? And so my point is like, you know, those people are moving really fast and it's totally insane. But when you zoom up really far and you're looking from a blimp or from a stadium seat, it just looks like little ants moving really slowly. And so you can watch football and kind of get an idea of what's going on. But for e-gamingaming it doesn't really work like you're seeing the same screen as the person playing and it's just it's just a total blur right hmm maybe they need a special view for spectators
这很明显，但除非你真的进入球场，否则它并没有真正意义。就像你，你知道，就像这些球员被擒抱，有时他们会摔倒四码，我的意思是，这太疯狂了，它是 12 英尺，就像有人摔倒了两个人的高度，对吧？所以我的观点是，你知道，那些人移动得非常快，这完全是疯狂的。但当你缩小画面，从飞艇或体育场座位上看时，它看起来就像小蚂蚁在缓慢移动。所以你可以看足球，并对正在发生的事情有一个概念。但对于电子竞技，它并没有真正起作用，就像你看到的是和玩游戏的人一样的屏幕，它只是，它只是一片模糊，对吧？嗯，也许他们需要一个专门给观众看的视角，
you know where it's zoomed out but then you wouldn't be able to really make anything out you know or maybe just there's a out, but then you wouldn't be able to really make anything out, you know. Or maybe just... There's a reason why football fields are very bland looking, right? Yeah, and I guess it's been around for longer, right? That football, there are lots of kinds of sports that aren't televised. I assume so, I don't know. Or failed sports that nobody even plays anymore just because they're not conducive, not interesting, whatever.
你知道，缩小画面，但那样你就无法看清任何东西了，你知道，或者也许只是……足球场看起来很平淡是有原因的，对吧？是的，而且我想它存在的时间更长了，对吧？足球，有很多种运动是不转播的。我想是的，我不知道。或者失败的运动，没人再玩了，仅仅因为它们不适合，不有趣，或者其他什么。
So that's kind of a self-fulfilling thing. Football was interesting to people and it made good TV, which meant people were invested in tweaking it to make good TV. So eventually we'll come across a game that's both fun to play and very suitable for streaming. And then it'll catch on. Yeah. I think, though, there's actually, like,
所以这是一种自我实现的预言。足球对人们来说很有趣，它制作了很好的电视节目，这意味着人们投入其中来调整它以制作更好的电视节目。所以最终我们会遇到一个既好玩又非常适合流媒体的游戏。然后它就会流行起来。是的。但我认为，实际上，有，
I think there's definitely something to making, like, basically two views of a game. So there's the person who's playing gets one view, but then if you're watching, you know, if you're a spectator watching professionals play, the graphics will just change for you in other words like all the details of like the trees all that stuff kind of becomes very bland so that you could understand what's going on like almost like cheating but uh but
我认为在制作，比如，基本上游戏的两个视图方面肯定有文章可做。所以玩游戏的人得到一个视图，但如果你在看，你知道，如果你是一个观看专业人士比赛的观众，图形会为你改变。换句话说，就像树木的所有细节之类的东西变得非常平淡，这样你就能理解正在发生什么，几乎就像作弊一样，但，但
the actual people playing don't get that luxury you know well for the starcraft competitions i know they like remove the fog of war so that you know you can kind of see the ambush about to happen and stuff so that's similar to what you're saying yeah that's right yep cool um but yeah i agree i think it's it's a total mess it's like it's everything is a surprise like you go to watch olympics like surprise you know you need a Comcast account right and I don't know I think I see your point that it probably won't get fixed either it's kind of sad but on the flip side there's a lot of really awesome entertainment on YouTube and other sources um okay so on to news um this is pretty cool. This is one of these security things I don't really know, don't have a strong background in, but it's actually okay because this link kind of, it's a presentation from a team called Team Pangu. team pangu and they're the team that has um jail done the jailbreak on the most recent iphones
实际玩游戏的人没有那种奢侈，你知道。嗯，对于星际争霸比赛，我知道他们会移除战争迷雾，这样你知道，你可以看到即将发生的伏击之类的，所以这和你说的很像。是的，没错。是的，酷。嗯，但是的，我同意，我认为这完全是一团糟，就像一切都是惊喜。就像你去观看奥运会，惊喜，你知道，你需要一个 Comcast 账户，对吧？我不知道，我想我明白你的观点，它可能也不会得到解决，这有点悲哀。但在另一方面，YouTube 和其他来源上有很多非常棒的娱乐内容。嗯，好的，那么新闻，这很酷。这是安全方面的事情之一，我不太了解，没有很强的背景，但实际上没关系，因为这个链接，它是来自一个叫 Team Pangu 的团队的演示。Team Pangu，他们是那个在最近的 iPhone 上完成了越狱的团队，
and so they actually walk step by step through um how to jailbreak um you know an ios 7 and they actually walk you through how to do it to your own phone but they walk through like specifically in terms of like the firmware and the software and the buffers and like exactly what is happening when you jailbreak your phone and they describe sort of the arms race uh between them and apple so they say you know oh look ios 7 we did this and then apple countered with this and then ios 8 we did that and uh you know it it's a PowerPoint presentation so it's meant to be delivered to like a lay audience not super technical but it's really cool the other thing I didn't realize these people who do the jailbreaks are all Chinese which which is pretty cool I had no idea that it was
所以他们实际上一步一步地走过，嗯，如何越狱，你知道，iOS 7，他们实际上引导你如何在你自己的手机上做，但他们走过，就像专门在固件、软件、缓冲区方面，以及当你越狱手机时到底发生了什么，他们描述了他们和苹果之间的军备竞赛。所以他们说，你知道，哦看，iOS 7 我们做了这个，然后苹果用这个反击，然后 iOS 8 我们做了那个，而且，你知道，这是一个 PowerPoint 演示文稿，所以它是为了传达给像外行观众，不是超级技术性的，但它真的很酷。另一件事我没意识到，这些做越狱的人都是中国人，这很酷。我根本不知道它是
like a team out of China. I think it's awesome. And they kind of did a really good job kind of explaining who they are, what they've done. And it's part of a, they actually run a mobile security conference called Mosec. You can go to mosec.org and check it out and actually that's in shanghai so if you're a you know security expert and you want to check out shanghai you could get your boss to yeah to get you to go to this conference um but yeah i thought it was super cool and interesting i always kind of wonder how these hacks actually work and uh and so they explain in pretty good detail
一个来自中国的团队。我觉得这太棒了。他们做得很好，解释了他们是谁，他们做了什么。这是其中的一部分，他们实际上运行一个名为 Mosec 的移动安全会议。你可以去 mosec.org 查看它，实际上那是在上海，所以如果你是一个，你知道，安全专家，你想去上海看看，你可以让你的老板，是的，让你去参加这个会议。但是的，我觉得这超级酷和有趣。我总是有点好奇这些黑客攻击实际上是如何工作的，而且，所以他们解释得相当详细。
so is there any i mean particular reason why it's a group out of china like and so they explain in pretty good detail so is there any i mean particular reason why it's a group out of china like what do they explain the motivation or just they happen to be the people most interested in it um yeah it's a good question like it's obviously a lot of work you know i guess if you're a security researcher maybe it's paid work to do that but that's one of the things that always interests me is, are people just that generous with their free time and that's what they want to work on? Well, this is definitely a company where they're getting paid somehow. Okay. My guess is, yeah, like who would pay to have a jailbreak for iPhone? I mean, obviously users, but no single user would pay enough money to justify it.
所以有什么，我的意思是，特别的原因为什么它是一个来自中国的团队吗？就像，他们解释了动机，还是他们碰巧是对此最感兴趣的人？嗯，是的，这是一个好问题，就像这显然是很多工作，你知道，我猜如果你是一个安全研究员，也许这是有偿工作，但这是总是让我感兴趣的事情之一，人们真的对他们的空闲时间那么慷慨吗？这就是他们想做的吗？嗯，这绝对是一家他们以某种方式获得报酬的公司。好的。我的猜测是，是的，就像谁会付钱让 iPhone 越狱？我的意思是，显然是用户，但没有单个用户会支付足够的钱来证明它是合理的。
And they're not really crowdfunding it. Yeah, it's a great question, right? Like, you know, where's like follow the money, right? I don't know. Yeah, I mean, if anybody out out there knows any of our listeners know like just in general security firms uh that do like commercial hacking like hack the ps4 hack the iphone hack the android like sort of like who really funds those i assume some of the hat many of the hacks are done by people trying to get money right so I'm
而且他们并没有真正众筹它。是的，这是一个很好的问题，对吧？就像，你知道，钱在哪里，对吧？我不知道。是的，我的意思是，如果外面有任何人，我们的听众知道，就像一般的安全公司，做商业黑客攻击，比如黑掉 PS4，黑掉 iPhone，黑掉 Android，就像，谁真正资助这些？我假设许多黑客攻击是由试图赚钱的人完成的，对吧？所以我
trying to hack your account so I can use as a botnet to make you click on my ads or click on the ads of my competitor whatever it is that botnets do so there's that kind of hacking and so there's security researchers who spend a lot of time researching that so they can kind of show how like in white papers how smart they are that people will pay them to check out their stuff to make sure it's correct so it's like a proof of work i guess because they can't talk about that makes sense can't talk about i i went to jace jason co and found 20 flaws and fixed them because Jason co doesn't want to admit that it had any flaws. And so you have to do it in like this way where you can kind of show your prowess. That makes sense. I mean, the other thing is if I, if I knew a group of people who are all very
试图黑掉你的账户，这样我就可以用它作为僵尸网络让你点击我的广告，或者点击我竞争对手的广告，无论僵尸网络做什么。所以有那种黑客攻击，所以有安全研究员花很多时间研究它，这样他们就可以在白皮书中展示他们有多聪明，人们会付钱让他们检查他们的东西以确保它是正确的。所以这就像工作证明，我想，因为他们不能谈论，这说得通，不能谈论，我去了 Jason Co 并发现了 20 个漏洞并修复了它们，因为 Jason Co 不想承认它有任何漏洞。所以你必须以这种方式做，你可以展示你的实力。这说得通。我的意思是，另一件事是如果我，如果我认识一群人，他们都是非常
reputable in the security realm, and I was a giant company like a Google or a Microsoft or something, then maybe I would fund it. You know, in other words, like like they did, Microsoft has like gives all their employees, I'm sure, Windows phones. And so if there's an exploit in the Windows phone, then like that means someone can read Microsoft employee emails and Microsoft so big they they could afford to you know pay one of these teams to try to hack their phone just to prevent that right there's also bounties some companies do if you find a flaw they'll give you you know decent sized monetary rewards yep yep um interesting Yep. Interesting. My next news article or link is to godbolt.org, G-O-D-B-O-L-T.org.
在安全领域享有盛誉，而我是一家像 Google 或 Microsoft 这样的大公司，那么也许我会资助它。你知道，换句话说，就像他们做的那样，Microsoft 有，我敢肯定，给他们所有的员工 Windows 手机。所以如果 Windows 手机中有一个漏洞，那么这意味着有人可以阅读 Microsoft 员工的电子邮件，而 Microsoft 如此之大，他们负担得起，你知道，付钱给这些团队之一尝试黑掉他们的手机只是为了防止这种情况，对吧？还有赏金，有些公司会做，如果你发现一个漏洞，他们会给你，你知道，相当大额的货币奖励。是的，是的，嗯，有趣。是的，有趣。我的下一篇新闻文章或链接是 godbolt.org，G-O-D-B-O-L-T.org。
And I don't, I mean, I guess I don't, that doesn't explain what it is at all. But what it is, is a place for you, it's a compiler explorer for C++. It may support other stuff, but that was mostly how I came across it. and it's a way of typing in source code in one panel of the website and on the other panel is the assembly output from gcc targeting various processors but i think mostly intel maybe only intel and it will show you what the assembly instructions generated by the compiler for your source code are. And they have a little example. Oh, that's cool.
我不知道，我的意思是，我猜我不知道，那根本没有解释它是什么。但它是什么，是一个为你提供的地方，它是 C++ 的编译器资源管理器。它可能支持其他东西，但这主要是我是如何遇到它的。这是一种在网站的一个面板中输入源代码，而在另一个面板中是针对各种处理器的 GCC 的汇编输出的方法，但我认为主要是 Intel，也许只有 Intel，它会向你展示编译器为你的源代码生成的汇编指令是什么。他们有一个小例子。哦，那很酷。
That it starts off with. It's not really that interesting, but you can kind of see it pushing onto the stack and kind of the rudimentary stuff. But where it really starts getting interesting is where you put in a little more elaborate code or you start adding compiler optimizations like turning on optimization level three. So that's dash O three for GCC. And then watching kind of what it does with the code as a result of that. So in the kind of-
它从那里开始。它其实没那么有趣，但你可以看到它推入堆栈和那种基础的东西。但它真正开始变得有趣的地方是当你放入更复杂的代码，或者你开始添加编译器优化，比如开启优化级别 3。所以那是 GCC 的 dash O 3。然后观察它作为结果对代码做了什么。所以在那样的-
Whoa, that's cool. Yeah. I just did it. And it went from like 10 instructions to four. Yeah, exactly. So in the kind of naive non-optimized way, it's doing a lot more so you can see what's happening. But when you start turning on optimizations in the kind of naive, non-optimized way, it's doing a lot more so you can see what's happening. But when you start turning on optimizations in the compiler, the code gets much more compact.
哇，那很酷。是的。我刚刚做了。它从 10 条指令变成了 4 条。是的，完全正确。所以在那样的天真、未优化的方式中，它做了更多的事情，所以你可以看到正在发生什么。但当你开始在编译器中开启优化时，代码变得紧凑多了。
You could also do like OS for optimize for size. Oh, apparently I typed big S. It's a little less. Yeah, they work now. I have three. And so you can start to play with examples and see what happens even if you don't understand the assembly just to kind of see how it interacts is interesting but then as you start to do the uh will it do the uh um what's it called the sim d like if you have a for loop will it it will do unrolling it will do some unrolling but i don't know if it'll do sim d i don't you maybe it will i i would assume it does if you
你也可以做像 OS 这样针对大小进行优化。哦，显然我输入了大写的 S。它少了一点。是的，它们现在起作用了。我有三个。所以你可以开始玩例子，看看会发生什么，即使你不理解汇编，只是看看它是如何交互的也很有趣。但随后当你开始做，嗯，它会做，嗯，它叫什么来着，SIMD，如果你有一个 for 循环，它会做展开，它会做一些展开，但我不知道它是否会做 SIMD，我不，也许它会，我假设如果
know what the inch the flag for it is oh right yeah cool this is awesome um it was just really interesting to me so typing it in playing it with myself by myself was sort of interesting but then going online and seeing examples other people had of interesting results was really cool too. So in some cases, kind of writing two equivalent expressions will produce vastly different results, like the difference between a one line function and a hundred line function because of how the optimizations in the compiler work. It was able to kind of detect an equivalency for one example, but not for the other. And so it just sort of
你知道它的标志是什么，哦，对，是的，酷，这太棒了。嗯，这对我来说真的很有趣，所以自己输入它，自己玩它，这很有趣，但随后上网看到其他人有有趣结果的例子也真的很酷。所以，在某些情况下，编写两个等效的表达式会产生截然不同的结果，比如一行函数和一百行函数之间的区别，因为编译器中的优化是如何工作的。它能够检测到一个例子的等价性，但不能检测到另一个。所以它只是那种
unexpected corner cases of compiler optimization are interesting and you see a lot of those online from people who have played around with it I'm gonna try I'm gonna try I've always wondered this I've always wondered if it mattered if you did post fix or prefix incrementer inside of the for loop. And I'm going to prove it to myself one way or the other right now. Or at least for GCC version 6.3. So for GCC version 6.3. No optimization.
编译器优化的意外边缘情况很有趣，你在网上从那些玩过它的人那里看到了很多。我要试一试，我要试一试，我一直想知道这个，我一直想知道在 for 循环中使用后缀或前缀增量器是否有关系。我现在要以一种或另一种方式向自己证明这一点。或者至少对于 GCC 6.3 版本。所以对于 GCC 6.3 版本。没有优化。
Wait, should I do optimization? Do it without. I feel like I should do it without starting. Okay, I'll do without and I'll do with. Oh, this is such a lot with good live uh podcasting but but while jason does that he'll come back with his results in a minute oh there he goes i can tell you right now it's 16 it's 15 instructions if i do a plus plus if i do plus plus a it's exactly the same uh so yeah so it turns out this is something that i i think i told the audience
等等，我应该做优化吗？不带优化做。我觉得我不应该从一开始就做。好的，我不带优化做，我也会带优化做。哦，这真是很多好的现场播客，但当 Jason 做那个的时候，他一会儿会带着结果回来。哦，他去了，我现在可以告诉你，它是 16，如果我做 a++，它是 15 条指令，如果我做 ++a，它是完全一样的。所以是的，所以事实证明这是某件事，我想我告诉过听众
like a year ago that it doesn't matter well for a primitive for a primitive in the for loop where you're not using the result that's right yeah it doesn't it doesn't matter if it's as you said like an int like if it's if it's you know object said, like an int. Like if it's, you know, object plus plus and you've defined the prefix operator to be way more efficient, then yeah, all bets are off. But yeah, this is totally cool. I mean, this is already useful. So for people,
大约一年前，它没关系。好吧，对于 for 循环中的原始类型，你没有使用结果，那是对的。是的，它没关系，如果它是，正如你所说的，像 int。如果它是，你知道，对象 ++，并且你已经定义了前缀运算符效率更高，那么是的，一切皆有可能。但是，是的，这完全很酷。我的意思是，这已经很有用了。所以对于人们，
Jason's going to go prove a bunch of coworkers wrong. So for people who are interested about assembly or want to poke around with this, this is actually very informative. Even without kind of knowing what all the Intel instructions are you can start to get a feel for it just by playing around with really simple instructions and seeing what's the same and what's different yeah that's awesome so yeah my news is JSON logic this is one of these things that's like,
Jason 要去证明一群同事错了。所以对于那些对汇编感兴趣或想摆弄这个的人来说，这实际上是非常有信息量的。即使不了解所有的 Intel 指令是什么，你也可以通过摆弄非常简单的指令并看看什么是相同的，什么是不同的，开始对它有感觉。是的，那太棒了。所以是的，我的新闻是 JSON Logic，这是那种像，
I have yet to think of a way this could be really useful, but it's just so interesting. I feel like there's got to be something useful in this. The idea is, as it suggests, it's effectively a programming language in JSON, where you write JSON. So JSON is this, you know, container format. So it's like XML and these other container formats. And so, you know,
我还没有想到一种方法这可能真的很有用，但它太有趣了。我觉得这里面一定有什么有用的东西。这个想法是，正如它所建议的，它实际上是 JSON 中的一种编程语言，你在其中编写 JSON。所以 JSON 是这个，你知道，容器格式。所以它就像 XML 和这些其他容器格式。所以，你知道，
typically JSON would hold, you know, a document with a bunch of fields like name, colon, JSON, age, colon, blah, blah, blah, right? And JSON can hold objects, it can hold arrays, it can have arrays of objects of arrays, et cetera, et cetera. And it has a really nice representation for storing data. The question always becomes, let's say you're trying to describe a topology of a neural network, or you're trying to describe some kind of process, like which function should I be using. You could have JSON and you could have a bunch of C++ code that looks at your JSON and then, you know, invokes the right object or looks at your JSON and then adds those two arguments together. This JSON logic actually lets you write code in JSON. You can add numbers in JSON.
通常 JSON 会保存，你知道，一个带有许多字段的文档，比如 name，冒号，JSON，age，冒号，等等，对吧？而且 JSON 可以保存对象，它可以保存数组，它可以有数组的数组对象，等等，等等。它有一个非常好的表示数据存储的方式。问题总是变成，假设你正在尝试描述神经网络的拓扑结构，或者你正在尝试描述某种过程，比如我应该使用哪个函数。你可以有 JSON，你可以有一堆 C++ 代码查看你的 JSON，然后，你知道，调用正确的对象，或者查看你的 JSON，然后将这两个参数加在一起。这个 JSON Logic 实际上让你在 JSON 中编写代码。你可以在 JSON 中添加数字。
You can have arbitrary equations in JSON. And then you can compile it with this or interpret it, I suppose, or interpreter. And so a good example of this would be if you have sort of a bunch of parameters, like one parameter kind of makes your website kind of slower in this way, but faster for images. And you have another parameter that kind of tweaks your website in some other way. And you want to sort of play with these parameters based on sort of what's happening. Like, oh, if a lot of people are getting images, I want to like boost my image stuff. So it's almost like you want this sort of equation,
你可以在 JSON 中有任意方程。然后你可以用这个编译它，或者解释它，我想，或者解释器。所以一个很好的例子是，如果你有一堆参数，比如一个参数让你的网站在这种方式下变慢，但对图像更快。而你有另一个参数以某种其他方式调整你的网站。你想根据正在发生的事情来摆弄这些参数。比如，哦，如果很多人在获取图像，我想提升我的图像东西。所以这几乎就像你想要这种方程，
but you want to be able to hot swap it. You want to be able to say, oh, I need my, you know, I want this parameter plus that parameter is equal to that parameter. And like, I want to make that change right away. This will let you do that. And so it looks kind of cool. As soon as I find a project that can use it, parameter is equal to that parameter and like i want to make that change right away um this will let you do that and so it looks kind of cool as soon as i find a project that can use it i will give it a shot and let you know how it goes my next link is to a collection of interesting bitwise
但你想要能够热交换它。你想要能够说，哦，我需要我的，你知道，我想要这个参数加那个参数等于那个参数。而且，你知道，我想立即做出那个改变。这会让你做到这一点。所以它看起来很酷。一旦我找到一个可以使用它的项目，参数等于那个参数，就像我想立即做出那个改变，嗯，这会让你做到这一点，所以它看起来很酷。一旦我找到一个可以使用它的项目，我会试一试，让你知道进展如何。我的下一个链接是关于一系列有趣的位
operators and tricks uh also an opportunity to talk about bitwise operators. But on this website, there are just, I don't, I didn't, they're not numbered and I didn't count them, but dozens of bitwise operations and what they do. And it's nothing complicated, just like how to calculate two to the end. Well, that one's a little obvious, I guess, you know, using left shift. Checking whether a number is a power of two. Then there's some more interesting stuff like averaging two numbers using bitwise operators trying to find some other good ones set the rightmost zero bit to one
运算符和技巧，嗯，也是一个谈论位运算符的机会。但在网站上，有，我不知道，我没有，它们没有编号，我也没有数它们，但有几十个位操作以及它们的作用。这没什么复杂的，就像如何计算 2 的 n 次方。嗯，那个有点明显，我想，你知道，使用左移。检查一个数字是否是 2 的幂。然后还有一些更有趣的东西，比如使用位运算符平均两个数字，试图找到其他一些好的，将最右边的零位设置为 1
turns out it's actually pretty easy fast inverse square root one of those is famous before the show we were talking about John Carmack one of those is famous because John before the show talking about John Carmack one of those is famous Because John Carmack used it in quake Is it inverse square root? I? Think I think he did these square root that might be but uh
事实证明这实际上很容易，快速平方根倒数，其中一个很有名，在节目之前我们谈到了 John Carmack，其中一个很有名，因为 John 在节目之前谈到了 John Carmack，其中一个很有名，因为 John Carmack 在 Quake 中使用了它。它是平方根倒数吗？我？想，我想他做了平方根，那可能是，但嗯
I'll look it up. No, it's fast inverse square root. Yep. It's Carmack and so The it's just a list Yeah, so there's just a list. Yeah. So there's just a list of kind of interesting operators. I don't know that there's a particular great reason to use these normally. I mean, they're really interesting. Your code is probably better off writing it all the way out
我会查一下。不，它是快速平方根倒数。是的。它是 Carmack，所以它只是一个列表。是的，所以它只是一个列表。是的，所以它只是一个列表，包含一些有趣的运算符。我不知道通常有什么特别好的理由使用这些。我的意思是，它们真的很有趣。你的代码可能最好把它全部写出来
than kind of using these condensed forms. But if you write really fast code. This has the advantage where it's very hard to get fired if you used a lot of these because you've made yourself absolutely critical. I'm just kidding. Yeah, I mean, yeah, I don't really see any reason for using these. Again, I think the compiler would do the optimization for you. So if you're really trying to get code size down
而不是使用这些压缩形式。但如果你写非常快的代码。这有一个优势，如果你使用了很多这些，你很难被解雇，因为你让自己变得绝对关键。我只是开玩笑。是的，我的意思是，是的，我真的没看到使用这些的任何理由。再说一次，我认为编译器会为你做优化。所以如果你真的想减小代码大小
or really trying to get something accomplished fast, these are really cool. They're also really awesome for just thinking about this. And what I do want to call this out as part of it is I've talked to various people who are kind of, you know, what are things to be ready for in preparing for an interview? And one of the things is bitwise operations come up a lot. And depending on where you are in the stack you maybe get away without it but for most people you know kind of understanding how computers work is sort of a given and part of how computers work is how bitwise operators work and so being prepared to kind of talk about binary forms of numbers and manipulating those is something that's pretty important.
或者真的想快速完成某事，这些真的很酷。它们对于思考这个问题也非常棒。而且我确实想把这作为它的一部分提出来，我已经和各种人谈过，他们是，你知道，准备面试时要准备什么？其中之一是位操作经常出现。而且根据你在堆栈中的位置，你也许可以不用它，但对于大多数人来说，你知道，理解计算机是如何工作的算是一种既定事实，而计算机工作方式的一部分就是位运算符是如何工作的，所以准备好谈论数字的二进制形式并操作它们是相当重要的。
So if you don't know that and you're kind of doing anything except for super, super high level work, that's something worth thinking about. And a page like this, although you may not remember them and you probably shouldn't use them, will get you thinking about those
所以如果你不知道这一点，而且你除了超级、超级高级的工作之外什么都在做，那是值得思考的事情。像这样的页面，虽然你可能记不住它们，而且你可能不应该使用它们，但会让你思考这些
and kind of being a puzzle. See if you can figure out or at least looking at it, understand why it works um even if you couldn't yeah that's a really good point i think that's also a lot of these have references like it's not just here's a line of code it actually have a link to a document explaining exactly what it's doing yep and so um this is something i'd recommend for any of you who are kind of trying to interview or just interested in low-level code um to kind of brush up on bitwise operators there's there's lots of links like this this is just one i happened to run across that i thought was
并且像一个谜题。看看你是否能弄清楚，或者至少看着它，理解它为什么起作用，嗯，即使你不能。是的，那是一个非常好的观点。我认为很多这些都有参考资料，就像它不仅仅是这里有一行代码，它实际上有一个链接到解释它到底在做什么的文档。是的，所以，嗯，这是我会推荐给你们中任何试图面试或只是对底层代码感兴趣的人，嗯，去复习一下位运算符。有很多像这样的链接，这只是我碰巧遇到的一个，我觉得
had some kind of nifty operators in there yeah this is really cool i actually sat on an interview years ago where the the candidate was interviewing for a firmware engineer job and uh there was all sorts of questions like this like there was a bunch of numbers that were packed into three bits each uh you know so as is uh each number was packed into three bits and you had to sort of unpack them and things like that time for book of the show Each number was packed into three bits. And you had to sort of unpack them and things like that. Time for book of the show. Book of the show.
里面有一些很棒的运算符。是的，这真的很酷。我几年前实际上参加过一次面试，候选人正在面试固件工程师的工作，嗯，有各种各样这样的问题，就像有一堆数字被打包成每个 3 位，嗯，你知道，所以是，嗯，每个数字被打包成 3 位，你必须把它们解包之类的。节目书的时间到了。每个数字被打包成 3 位。你必须把它们解包之类的。节目书的时间到了。节目书。
My book of the show is Richard Dawkins is the author. The book is The Selfish Gene. This is, I mean, I don't know if you'd call this controversial or not, but this is absolutely. So Richard Dawkins is an evolutionary biologist. And so, you know, the whole book is explaining a facet of evolution. But the idea is, you know, there's evolution, there's survival of the fittest, and there's a lot of these terms that Charles Darwin and others have sort of coined that have become part of common core, like what most people understand. But then there's this idea, like, there's sort of this number of things that sort of are, you know, a little counterintuitive. Like, for example, you know, cancer can kill almost anyone. There's some viruses that are incredibly
本期我推荐的书是理查德·道金斯（Richard Dawkins）所著的《自私的基因》。我不知道这算不算有争议，但它确实非常出名。理查德·道金斯是一位演化生物学家，整本书都在阐述演化的一个侧面。书中提到的核心概念是演化和适者生存，这些查尔斯·达尔文等人提出的术语已经成为大众普遍理解的常识。但书中也提出了一些反直觉的观点，例如，癌症几乎可以杀死任何人，还有一些病毒极其
powerful. And so why is humanity getting more and more complicated? Or why is just nature getting more and more complicated? You know, even those simple things seem to be very efficient and very powerful. You know, it doesn't seem to fit with the survival of the fittest, right? And so that concept is called the arrow of complexity. The idea that just complexity in the universe keeps increasing, we don't really know why. There's another idea, which is if you believe in survival of the fittest kind of on an individual level, then a lot of these systems like ecological systems become unstable if you were to model them in this way. In other words, if all the lions are trying to kill and eat as many zebra as possible, then what happens is all the lions eat all the zebra and then everyone starves you know and so uh um you know people had kind of wondered oh maybe there's enough zebras that are faster than the lions that they live to an old age and stuff like that but even
强大。那么，为什么人类变得越来越复杂？或者说，为什么自然界变得越来越复杂？即使是那些简单的生物似乎也非常高效且强大。这似乎与“适者生存”不符，对吧？这个概念被称为“复杂性之箭”。即宇宙中的复杂性在不断增加，我们并不真正知道原因。另一个观点是，如果你相信个体层面的适者生存，那么像生态系统这样的许多系统在建模时就会变得不稳定。换句话说，如果所有的狮子都试图杀死并吃掉尽可能多的斑马，结果就是狮子吃光了所有斑马，然后大家都饿死了。人们曾想，也许有足够多跑得比狮子快的斑马能活到老，但即使
then it's like a very unstable equilibrium and it didn't seem very likely um richard dawkins tackles a lot of these issues in the selfish gene which is i think super interesting um uh you know i mean just not to do too much of a spoiler but basically the idea is that the genetic code is the thing being selfish, not the individual. And so in other words, you know, a lion will not kill 10 zebras if it can only eat one. It will kill the one zebra and it will eat it. And it'll take us so much time to eat it that the other nine zebra get away, even if they're all slower. And so the idea is like richard dawkins makes this this conjecture that that you know the genetic code is selfish what that means is even if the lion can
那样，这似乎也是一种非常不稳定的平衡，不太可能持续。理查德·道金斯在《自私的基因》中探讨了许多这类问题，我觉得非常有趣。不想剧透太多，但基本观点是：自私的是基因密码，而不是个体。换句话说，如果狮子一次只能吃一只斑马，它就不会杀死10只。它会杀死那一只并吃掉它，而吃完需要花费很多时间，这让其他9只斑马得以逃脱，即使它们跑得更慢。理查德·道金斯推测，基因密码是自私的，这意味着即使狮子能够
kill 10 zebras it just won't um because the zebras and the lions are sharing much of the same genetic code and that code is trying to be as diverse as possible so if for whatever reason lions can't survive anymore the genes themselves get to live on in the zebras or the fish right or whatever so the book covers a ton of things i mean this is just one of them and he's also written several other books but i just think these things are fascinating. I was very fortunate to have been able to ask Richard Dawkins a question. He was a keynote speaker at a conference and he also took questions. And our team kind of submitted a question, which he answered.
杀死10只斑马，它也不会这样做，因为斑马和狮子共享许多相同的基因密码，而这些密码试图尽可能多样化。所以，如果因为某种原因狮子无法再存活，基因本身还能在斑马或鱼类等其他生物身上延续。这本书涵盖的内容非常多，这只是其中之一。他还写过其他几本书，但我认为这些内容非常迷人。我有幸向理查德·道金斯提过一个问题。他曾是某次会议的主旨演讲嘉宾，并接受了提问。我们的团队提交了一个问题，他回答了。
You know, we were kind of asking about this era of complexity and uh um you know we asked like how this was actually before i think he actually ended up writing about it later but this was you know back like 2004 um he actually explained kind of what he thought um about that era of complexity and he thought that it was um trying to get new food that basically you know effectively like trees are trying to get new food. That basically, you know, effectively like trees are trying to find new ways to keep the food away from us or make it harder to reach and animals are trying to find new ways to get that food and that sort of arms race is sort of what's making things more and more complex. But yeah, I think it's a super interesting read.
我们当时问的是关于“复杂性之箭”的问题。这其实是在他后来专门写到这个话题之前，大概是在2004年。他解释了他对复杂性之箭的看法，他认为这就像是树木试图获取新的养分。实际上，树木试图寻找新的方法来防止我们获取它们的果实，或者让果实更难采摘，而动物则试图寻找新的方法来获取这些食物。这种军备竞赛正是导致事物变得越来越复杂的原因。但我认为这本书非常值得一读。
Highly recommend it my book of the show is Abaddon's Gate by James S.A. Corey which is a pen name for actually two authors but this is the third book in the Expanse series and I can't say much about it since it's the third book obviously I read books one and two. It's a nine to the third. And I'm, you know, so I guess the test for a series like that is whether you're going to read the next book.
强烈推荐。我本期推荐的书是詹姆斯·S·A·科里（James S.A. Corey）的《阿波罗之门》（Abaddon's Gate）。这是两个作者合用的笔名，也是《苍穹浩瀚》（The Expanse）系列的第三部。因为是第三部，我不能透露太多，显然我读了第一部和第二部。这是三部曲中的第三部。我想，这类系列书的考验在于你是否会继续读下一本。
And so I think I'll probably read book four. So I guess that's a recommendation for book three. Why would they do a pen name? Do you know? So I think just because it's a little easier to sell rather than having two authors names on you know so people i don't that's a good question they probably have answered it um there's several interviews with the two authors i'm sorry i'm not saying their names right now i don't remember what they were um but they kind of write as this person they can kind of give this person their own character i guess and and then write that way and the series is pretty good
我想我可能会读第四本。所以这算是对第三本的推荐。你知道他们为什么要用笔名吗？我想只是因为这样比写两个作者的名字更容易销售。这是个好问题，他们可能回答过。关于这两位作者的采访有很多，抱歉我现在说不出他们的名字，我不记得了，但他们以这个人的身份写作，我想他们可以赋予这个角色独特的性格，然后以那种方式创作。这个系列相当不错。
and one of the things is i i didn't actually kind of realize that the tv version on the sci-fi channel sifi channel i don't know how you say that that oh yeah they changed it sifi or something yeah and so on that channel i watched the first couple episodes of the Expanse TV series. And although it's not kind of accurate to page by page in the book, they have very much the same feel and very much the same themes. And I found it, although it's a little, it's pretty dark. It's overall the series itself is kind of dark um and so the the tv show was pretty dark but i found myself enjoying it and i saw a brief interview with the two authors who consult heavily the authors i can tell you the names are daniel abraham and ty frank okay thank you the internet it's so useful um and so they were interviewing them about the expanse tv show and one of the things they were saying is that they don't they're writers of the book and they consult and kind of give ideas but ultimately there are people who understand writing for tv choosing what themes
有一件事我之前没意识到，就是科幻频道（Syfy）播出的电视版。哦对，他们改名了，叫Syfy还是什么的。我在那个频道看了《苍穹浩瀚》电视剧的前几集。虽然它在情节上没有完全忠实于原著，但感觉和主题非常一致。我觉得它虽然有点黑暗，但整个系列本身就是黑暗风格的，所以电视剧也很黑暗，但我发现自己很喜欢它。我看了两位作者的简短采访，他们深度参与了制作。作者的名字是丹尼尔·亚伯拉罕（Daniel Abraham）和泰·弗兰克（Ty Franck）。好的，谢谢互联网，它太有用了。采访中提到，他们是书的作者，担任顾问并提供想法，但最终还是由懂电视创作的人来决定哪些主题
to pull forward and what parts of the story to modify to make it make sense for tv so they're not what they call those like screenwriters, I guess. Those people, and they consult with the two authors, but they're trying to have a relationship so that it doesn't have to be true to the book at the expense of bad TV, but not great TV and leave just, it's just inspired by the book. So it strikes a good middle ground.
要突出，哪些故事部分需要修改以适应电视呈现。他们不是所谓的编剧。那些人会咨询这两位作者，但他们试图建立一种合作关系，这样就不必为了忠实于原著而牺牲电视节目的质量，而是让剧集受到原著的启发。这达成了一个很好的平衡。
Yeah, it's similar to The Walking Dead. You know, like The Walking Dead, you know, at first I read all the comics. And then when the show came out, I was like, hey, Linz, to my wife, I was like, hey, you should check out this show. And I kind of was pretty sure she wasn't going to like it because the book is sort of very kind of tactical and it talks a lot about you know surviving in the zombie apocalypse and and it's also kind of gruesome and there's just not a lot of like touchy-feely or like emotion type stuff in in the comic um and and uh when we watched it we we both realized that like they actually kind of made it into more of a drama to fit sort of the TV medium. And as a result, we both now really like it.
是的，这和《行尸走肉》很像。比如《行尸走肉》，起初我读了所有的漫画。当电视剧出来时，我对妻子林兹说，你应该看看这部剧。我当时很确定她不会喜欢，因为原著非常讲究战术，谈论了很多在僵尸末日中生存的细节，而且有点血腥，漫画里没有太多温情或情感类的东西。当我们看的时候，我们都意识到他们实际上把它改编成了更符合电视媒介的剧情片。结果，我们现在都很喜欢它。
Yeah, so The Expanse is good. If you aren't really a book reader, but you do watch TV, I'd recommend checking out the TV series. And if you've read the book and you haven't checked out the TV series, do that as well, because you'll kind of know what's you don't know what's about to happen, but you kind of know what's going to happen, if that makes sense. So eventually the things you know are going to happen are going to happen, but they may happen sort of differently than you expect. Yep. So it's still worth watching is what I'm saying. Cool. And what is that's on? Oh, it's on SIFI. So I guess you'd get that through like Hulu, Netflix, or that other thing that we don't pay attention to.
是的，《苍穹浩瀚》很棒。如果你不是书迷但喜欢看电视，我建议看看电视剧。如果你读过书但没看过电视剧，也去看看，因为你虽然不知道接下来会发生什么，但你大概知道会发生什么，这说得通吧？所以最终你知道会发生的事情还是会发生，但发生的方式可能和你预期的不同。是的，所以它仍然值得一看。酷。那是在哪个频道播的？哦，在Syfy。所以你可以通过Hulu、Netflix或者我们不怎么关注的其他平台看到。
Well, they're streaming TV as well. If you have TV that streams SIFI. Yeah, there's lots of ways to get it. I'm not going to go through them all. Gotcha. Depending on your will. Yeah. Anyways. And I actually listened to that on Audible because I have a long commute and that's how I do most of my reading. I just call it reading. Maybe that's unethical, immoral. I think it's reading. No, I think you're of sci-fi. And then they were kind of like looked at me and I'm like, okay, well, I don't read it. I listened to it. And they were like, what? And I was like in the car because I commute and then I just listened to it.
嗯，他们也有流媒体。如果你有能播放Syfy的电视服务。是的，有很多获取渠道。我就不一一列举了。明白了。取决于你的意愿。总之。我实际上是在Audible上听的，因为我通勤时间很长，我大部分阅读都是这样完成的。我直接称之为阅读。也许这不道德、不合规？我认为这就是阅读。不，我想你是科幻迷。当时他们看着我，我说，好吧，我不读，我听。他们说，什么？我说在车里，因为我要通勤，我就听。
And they were saying how they couldn't do it. But for me, it's really good because it allows me to kind of do something I enjoy, which is reading these books. But I don't have a lot of time to sit down and actually you know do page turning yeah exactly do you like have you ever um you know started like i mean have you ever got so lost in that world that you just show up at work and you're just like what happened yes
他们说他们做不到。但对我来说，这真的很好，因为它让我能做我喜欢的事情，也就是阅读这些书。但我没有太多时间坐下来翻书。是的，完全正确。你有没有曾经沉浸在那个世界里，以至于到了公司才回过神来，心想刚才发生了什么？是的。
like i feel like that's that would happen to me almost every day it does happen to me sometimes and it's really scary. And I don't know whether I actually was paying attention on the road and then my brain just didn't bother to record it. A slew of just carnage behind you. Yeah. But anyways, so this is also Audible is a sponsor of this show. And so if you've never tried Audible before. Not anymore.
我觉得我几乎每天都会这样。有时确实会发生，这真的很可怕。我不知道我当时是否真的在注意路况，还是我的大脑根本没记录下来。身后留下一片狼藉。是的。总之，Audible是本节目的赞助商。如果你从没试过Audible。不再是了。
Oh, dear. I'm just kidding. Anyways, if you're interested, they have a thing where they'll give you the first book free as like a part of a trial. And then after you get that book, you're welcome to cancel the subscription. And what they do,
哦，天哪。我开玩笑的。总之，如果你感兴趣，他们有一个活动，试用期内可以免费获得第一本书。拿到书后，你可以随时取消订阅。他们通常的做法是，
the typical thing is you get one book a month, one credit a month, which is good. I've never found a book that was more than a credit, but I guess it could happen. And so you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown. I really like Audible. I still pay for my own subscription, and I really enjoy the books I get on there. And kind of making my commute that much easier, well, it's still pretty crappy.
你每月获得一本书，每月一个积分，这很好。我从没发现哪本书需要超过一个积分，但我想这也有可能。你可以访问audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。我真的很喜欢Audible。我仍然在为自己的订阅付费，我很享受在上面听到的书。这让我的通勤轻松了一些，虽然通勤本身还是很糟糕。
But at least it's a little less crappy. Yeah. Actually, maybe next month's news, someone did this awesome visualization of traffic in the Bay Area. And I'll make that news next month if I remember. So I'm going to create a new slogan for Audible, making Patrick's commute a little less crappy. There you go. I'll send that to them. We're also on Patreon. So you should go to patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown
但至少没那么糟糕了。是的。其实，也许下个月的新闻可以提一下，有人做了一个关于湾区交通的超棒可视化图表。如果我记得的话，下个月我会把它作为新闻。我要为Audible想个新口号：让帕特里克的通勤没那么糟糕。就这样。我会发给他们的。我们也在Patreon上。所以你应该访问patreon.com/programmingthrowdown
and that's how those that's how Josh P and Sam R got their free t-shirts they were lucky, Patreon subscribers but that really kind of helps us out, it goes straight to the show we have an account for it
这就是Josh P和Sam R获得免费T恤的方式，他们很幸运，是Patreon订阅者。这真的很有帮助，直接支持了节目，我们有专门的账户。
it's not like going into our pockets or anything like that. All of it gets redistributed back to help the show in some form or another. So thanks for that. And it's time for Tool of the Show. So my mission, every year I set a mission. I don't really call it a resolution because like I feel like resolution implies that there's a problem that you want to resolve. This is more just like a goal. And if I meet it, it's great.
这不会进我们的口袋。所有的钱都会以某种形式重新投入到节目中。所以谢谢你们。现在是“本期工具”时间。我的使命，我每年都会设定一个使命。我不称之为“决心”，因为我觉得决心暗示着有一个需要解决的问题。这更像是一个目标。如果我实现了，那很好。
If not, my life doesn't really change that much. It's always kind of something small. Like one year, I was look people in the eyes when I talk to them. Another year was just I think it was like something about being more polite. There was another, I don't know, it's, it's, it's, I've been doing this for a long time. Sometimes they're kind of technical. This year it's about organization. So I found when I was kind of reflecting back on the past few months that when I was kind of more organized at work, just, I got a lot more organized at work, just I got a lot more
如果没有，我的生活也不会有太大改变。通常是一些小事。比如有一年，我要求自己说话时看着对方的眼睛。还有一年是关于变得更有礼貌。还有别的，我不知道，我已经坚持很久了。有时它们是技术性的。今年是关于组织能力。我反思过去几个月时发现，当我在工作中更有条理时，我完成的工作量大得多。
done. The people around me got a lot more done. And I could actually just see this almost perfect correlation as I was kind of walking through the past few months, this perfect correlation between when I was organized and our sort of velocity and my velocity. Now, part of that is there's like a chicken and an egg there. Like part of it was, I was disorganized because it was a disorganized time
我周围的人也完成得更多。当我回顾过去几个月时，我能看到这种近乎完美的关联，即我的组织能力与我们的工作进度以及我个人的进度之间的关联。当然，这其中有“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题。比如，我之所以杂乱无章，是因为项目本身处于混乱时期。
in the project. And so, you know, I don't think that it's solely because of that, right? But it's still something I wanna work on. And it's not only getting more organized, but it's also being more efficient with the organizing. Like I want to be able to, you know, take notes, write to-dos, set deadlines for myself, get notified when it's close
所以，我不认为仅仅是因为这个原因，对吧？但这仍然是我想要改进的地方。不仅是变得更有条理，还要在组织过程中更高效。我想能够记笔记、写待办事项、为自己设定截止日期、在临近截止日期时收到通知，并在完成后勾选。我想快速完成所有这些，这样我就不必浪费太多时间。所以我的本期工具是Emacs Org Mode，“org”代表组织。对于非Emacs用户，Emacs有主要模式。如果你在编辑C++文件，你就在C++模式下。如果你在编辑HTML文件，你就在Web模式下。每个模式背后都有大量的逻辑，对吧？语法高亮完全不同，诸如此类。Org Mode只是一个
to those deadlines, check the box when I'm done with them. And I want to do all of this really quickly so I don't have to waste a lot of time. And so my tool of the show is this thing called Emacs Org Mode, org for organization. So for people who aren't Emacs users, Emacs has major modes. So the idea is if you're editing a C++ file, you're in C++ mode. If you're editing an HTML file, you're in web mode. And the mode, you know, there's like a massive amount of logic behind each mode, right? So the syntax highlighting is totally different, things like that. you know there's like a massive amount of logic behind each mode right so the syntax highlighting is totally different things like that org mode is just a
完全不同的环境，在Emacs内部，你有日历、待办事项列表，以及各种保持条理的方法。它极其复杂。我下载了它，安装过程很简单，我心想，让我看看手册。我原本以为可能只有8页，结果Org Mode的手册有300页，这让我
completely different environment inside Emacs where you have like a calendar you have like to-do lists and you have all these different ways to stay organized it's incredibly complicated I actually what I downloaded it and all that that was very straightforward and I was like oh let me check out the manual I was expecting you know maybe an 8 page manual there's like a 300 page manual on org mode which makes
觉得，也许剩下的还在用Emacs的人都是那些不再怎么写代码的人了。我不知道，Emacs用户的平均年龄可能现在是40岁左右吧。但它看起来很棒，我才刚刚开始使用。这就是我的本期工具。到目前为止，我可以肯定地说，你可以很快上手并用Org Mode做一些简单的事情。非常好。我的工具是cpplint.py，这是一个C++代码检查工具（linter），我想这是由谷歌制作的，
me think like maybe the only people left using emacs are people who like don't do that much coding anymore I don't know like the median age of emacs are people who like like don't do that much coding anymore i don't know like the median age of emacs users maybe now is like 40 or something but uh um but you know it looks awesome i'm just getting into it um and uh that's my tool of the show so far i've i can say that you know you can very quickly get up to speed and do some simple things with org mode very nice my tool is cpp lint.py which i is a c++ linter by i think this one's actually made
所以它是为了谷歌的风格指南设计的。但我同时也推荐LLVM或Clang的检查工具，它们的功能比谷歌风格指南更强大，实际上可以支持其他风格指南。总之，代码检查工具是我的本期工具，原因是我发现，无论你用什么语言编写代码，拥有一套风格指南都非常有用。我不是那种喜欢吹毛求疵的人，但保持一致性很重要，而我知道最简单的方法就是使用一个检查工具，每当有人做出更改时，它就会自动提示他们哪里不符合预期的风格。我不喜欢陷入争论。
by google so it's for the google style guide but i also simultaneously would recommend uh there's an llvm or i guess a clang linter as well that will do more than just the google style guide it actually can do other style guides anyway so linters are my tool of the show and the reason why is because i find that if you have a style guide for whatever code you're writing in whatever language that is super useful and i'm not a big proponent of nitpicking to death people but keeping everything consistent and the easiest way i know to do that is to have a linter that just every time someone makes a change just kind of already will tell them when they're not matching the expected style and I'm not much one I'm not one for getting into debating
谷歌有C++风格指南，我想还有Linux C风格指南，虽然那不是C++，但还有其他版本。前几天有人争论说新代码应该使用他们偏好的另一种风格。我问他们的一件事是，有没有针对那种风格的检查工具或规则？他们说没有。对我来说，这是一个巨大的减分项。我不想采用你的方式，不是因为我觉得它不好，而是如果你没有检查工具，这真的很令人沮丧，因为它不能让每个人都保持诚实，它允许人们
whether use Google has a C++ style guide I think there's a Linux C style guide there's which isn't C++ but then there's other versions and other people have style and someone you know kind of the other day was arguing for some new code to use this other kind of style that they preferred. And one of the things I asked them was, you know, is there a linter or have you kind of a lint rules for some linter for that? You're kind of your way you're saying that it should be done. And they were kind of like, well, no. And I was like, to me, that's a huge negative where I don't want to adopt your way, not because I particularly think it's bad, but if you don't have a linter for it, to me, that's really frustrating because it doesn't keep everyone honest and it doesn't allow, it allows people
在不想遵守时钻空子。这只会变得一团糟。所以我认为，让大家达成共识，然后使用检查工具，是一种避免冲突的方法。是的，解释一下，虽然我们在其他节目中提到过，但代码检查工具就是会查看你的源代码，并在你违反风格指南时告诉你。它会扫描你的整个源代码，说：“嘿，在第46行，你多了一个空格。”或者“第48行，那个换行符是不需要的。”此外还有格式化工具。
to kind of get away when they don't really want to do it or they don't particularly, you know, they don't agree with it. It's just messy messy and so i think just having everybody agree and then having a linter is a kind of way to not have conflict yeah and just to explain i mean we've covered this in other shows but but a linter is just something where it will look at your source code and tell you when you've violated the style guide like it'll actually scan your whole source code and say, hey, at line 46, you have an extra space. You're on line 48, you just new line doesn't need to be there. And then there's also a formatter.
比如Clang有检查工具，也有Clang format。哦，我想Clang检查工具是Clang format的一部分。对，是的。所以它甚至可以直接为你修复几乎所有的检查错误。酷。我也很抱歉，请继续。哦，我想说我和你一样，我不会在代码审查中强制执行规则，但我确实认为你需要一个系统来烦扰那些有错误的人。换句话说，我工作过的每个地方都有
Like there's like Clang has a linter and also Clang format. Oh, I guess the Clang linter is part of Clang format. Right, yeah. And so it will just, it can also just fix almost all the lint errors for you um cool and i'm not i'm also i'm sorry go ahead oh i was gonna say i'm the same way like i don't enforce the rules um in code reviews and things like that but i do think that you need a system that annoys people who have lint errors in other words like like there's a system every place i've worked has
一个系统，如果你在某个地方没加空格，当你尝试提交代码时，它会给你一个小警告。只要这个系统存在，我就把剩下的留给“荣誉系统”，让人们自己修复自己的问题。但如果这个系统不存在，那就如同西部荒野。你必须亲自、在社交层面去强制执行。没人想那样做。是的。这和我想要说的一样，我不会让检查工具成为硬性阻断。
had a system in place where you know if you put if you don't put a space somewhere it gives you a little warning when you try and submit your code and then as long as that system exists i i leave the rest up to the you know leave, leave it to the honor system, like let people fix their own issues. But if that system doesn't exist, then it's just like the Wild West. Like you have to enforce it, you know, personally, like socially. And nobody wants to do that. Yes. This is sort of similar to what I was going to say, which is I don't make the linter a hard fail.
有些人会这样做。但在我看来，有些时候如果你有充分的理由，应该被允许打破规则。我不在乎。但正如你所说，我以前待过的团队什么都没有。然后有人在代码审查中忘记了或者其他什么原因。然后你开始有一堆不合规的代码。然后必须去修改它。我认为拥有一套商定的风格指南
Some people do. But in my opinion, there are certain times when you should be allowed to kind of break it if you think there's a really good reason for it. And I'm not going to care. But as you said, I've been on teams before that had nothing. And then somebody just forgets or whatever in a code review. And then you start having a bunch of code that doesn't comply. And then it's a's essential to change it. And I think just having an agreed-upon style guide
能让代码易于阅读。是的，完全同意。所以代码检查工具是我的本期工具。太棒了。好的，那么PHP和Hack。首先，向Cyrus致敬。我们不会透露你的姓氏，但Cyrus给我们发了邮件说：
keeps the code easy to read. Yep, totally. So linters are my tool of the show. That's awesome. Yeah, so, all right, PHP and hack. So first, shout out to Cyrus. We won't spoil your last name, but Cyrus emailed us and said,
嘿伙计们，你们还没讲过PHP。为什么不聊聊PHP和WordPress呢？因为你发了邮件，这正是我们要做的。PHP在用户群方面是一个巨大的语言。很多人都在使用它。我们竟然没讲过它，真是太神奇了。我实际上还特意核实了一下，确保我们过去确实没讲过。
hey guys, you haven't done PHP. Why don't you talk about PHP and WordPress? And so because you emailed us, this is exactly what we're going to do. PHP is a huge language in terms of user base. Tons of people use it. It's amazing we haven't covered it. I actually had to do a double check to make sure we haven't covered it in the past.
为了引入PHP，大家都做过模板，对吧？例如，如果你使用printf，你写printf("我的名字是%s", name)。你甚至可以在逗号后面做各种疯狂的逻辑，可以是任何你想要的C代码，但最后它是一个字符串，那个%s会被逗号后面的内容替换。你可以写得很复杂。你可以用%2d，它会显示一个带两位小数的数字，等等。如果你使用Python，他们有format函数，做同样的事情。
And, you know, to kind of motivate PHP, you know, everyone's kind of done templating, right? Like, for example, if you do printf you do printf my name is percent s and then comma and then your name right you can even do all sorts of crazy logic after the comma it could be whatever c code you want but then at the end it's some string and then that percent s you know the the what you put in after that comma gets substituted into the percent s. And you could be really complicated. You could have percent 2d, and it puts a number there with two decimal places and everything, right? If you use Python, they have the format function, does the same thing.
它甚至有相同的语法。几乎每种语言都有某种类型的替换，某种做这种替换的方法。这被称为模板。所以PHP，至少在它刚开始时，实际上是一种用HTML做模板的方法。你可以写一堆HTML，然后，与printf有点不同，在printf的情况下，你写所有的%s，然后所有的参数都在后面。在PHP的情况下，你写所有的HTML，然后在HTML本身中，你使用PHP括号，
It even has the same syntax. You know, almost every language has some type of substitution, some way of doing substitution like that. And that's called templating. So PHP, at least when it started, is effectively a way to do templating with HTML. So you could write a bunch of HTML and then, a little different than printf, in the case of printf you do all these percent S's and then all of your arguments come afterwards, in the case of printf, you do all these percent S's, and then all of your arguments come afterwards. On the case of PHP, you write all this HTML, and then in the HTML itself, you do like a PHP bracket,
然后写一些PHP代码。但归根结底，它仍然是一种模板，类似于printf之类的东西，对吧？现在，为什么这很重要？把自己带回1990年代。浏览器当时简直疯了，iPhone还没出来，智能手机根本不存在。网页浏览器之间几乎没有任何兼容性。如果你能让它们以大致相同的方式渲染HTML，那就算你走运了。
and you have some PHP code. But at the end of the day, it's still kind of templating, like printf kind of stuff, right? Now, why is this important? So put yourself back to the 1990s right like um browsers were just crazy you know like the iphone wasn't out yet smartphones weren't really out yet really at all and uh and the web browsers there's just not really any compatibility. Like, you would be lucky if they all rendered the HTML even remotely the same way.
JavaScript就更别提了。如果你有一堆复杂的JavaScript，甚至简单的JavaScript，你根本无法保证90%的浏览器能正确渲染它。这意味着你必须在服务器端完成所有工作。所以有人点击一个复选框，你必须实际去服务器，重新渲染整个HTML，就像那个复选框被选中后整个宇宙看起来的样子，然后把它发送给客户端。客户端会刷新整个浏览器。如果你见过旧网站，比如你的医院医生网站可能还在这样工作。但这就是整个互联网的工作方式。
JavaScript, forget it. Like, if you had a bunch of complicated JavaScript or even simple JavaScript, you know, there's no way you could guarantee that even 90% of browsers would render it correctly. And so what that means is you have to do everything on the server side. So someone, you know, clicks a checkbox, you have to actually go to the server, you know, re-render the entire HTML, like what the whole universe looks like now that that checkbox has been checked, and send that over to the client. The client's going to refresh the whole browser. And I mean, if you've ever seen old websites, like maybe like your hospital doctor website still works this way or something. But like that's just, that's how the whole internet worked.
一切都在服务器上完成。所以，这使得像PHP这样的服务器模板库非常流行。很多人喜欢抨击PHP，我想是因为它像任何初学者编程语言一样，很多人把它作为第一门编程语言。当你这样做时，我认为它会受到很多批评或仇恨，被视为一种劣质语言，而且还有很多怪癖。但是，它确实有很多库。PHP已经存在很长时间了。它有很多支持。有很多不同的工具可以完成你需要做的事情。而且还有大量的
And everything was done on the server. And so, you know, that made these server templating libraries like php really popular php like a lot of people do like to rag on it i think because it's like any beginner programming language a lot of people kind of did it as one of their first programming languages and when you do that i think it opens it up to a lot of criticism or hate as a inferior language and also just quirkiness. But, you know, it does have a lot of libraries. PHP has been around for a while. There's a lot of support for it. There's a lot of different tools to get done what you need to get done and do the things you're trying to do in it. And there's also a ton of
教程，因为它是一门流行的初学者语言，所以很多人写关于它的文章，回答初学者倾向于遇到的常见问题。还有很多代码示例，很多遗留代码，你可以参考来理解如何做事情。是的，PHP做得很好的一点，不是语言本身，而是维护者做得很好，那就是文档。如果你输入“php printf”，然后去PHP网站查看printf文档，它们几乎是维基风格的，有官方文档，还有所有用户贡献的内容，而且他们从一个版本到另一个版本都保留了这些内容。
tutorials because it's such a popular beginner's, or has been a popular beginners language, then you get a lot of people writing about it and answering a lot of common problems that beginners tend to have. And a lot of code examples, a lot of legacy code that you can look at to kind of understand how to do stuff. Yep, one thing PHP does really well, I mean mean not the language itself but the the maintainers do really well is uh the documentation like if you were to like type php printf and you actually go to the php site and look at the printf documentation um they have it's almost like a wiki type style like there's the official documentation and then there's all this user contributed content and that they keep that from version to version
所以这很酷。如果你查一下“php printf”，你会看到人们说：“哦，这里有个技巧，这里有个方法。”如果你想打印一个对象，这里有代码。它几乎成了PHP的活手册，我觉得这很聪明。这也对初学者很有帮助。简单过一下PHP的细节，它是一门弱类型语言。所以你可以说“i = 3”，然后稍后如果你想
so um so it's pretty cool like if you look up even just printf uh php printf you'll see all these things like people say oh here's some hack for this here's some way to do that if you want to print an object here's some code and it's Here's some way to do that. If you want to print an object, here's some code. And it's just become, it's almost like a living manual of PHP, which I thought was kind of clever. And it also helps with the beginner aspect. Just to kind of breeze through some of the details of PHP, it's a weekly type language. So you just say, you know, I equals three. And then later on on if you want
说“i = jim”，也是可以的。关于数组，PHP只有对象，这有点像类。好吧，基本上PHP只有数组，但它们是关联数组。所以即使是对象和类也用这些关联数组表示。但这引出了一个问题：如果我只是想要一个包含10个数字的数组并进行索引呢？你实际上可以做到。你可以创建我们在C或C++中传统上称为数组的东西。PHP在底层仍然是关联数组，
to say i equals jim you can do that it's fine um it's all of the arrays so php only has uh object um which is kind of like a class and uh well it's it's basically php only has arrays but they're associative arrays. And so even objects and classes are kind of represented using these associative arrays. But it kind of begs the question, like, what if I just want an array of 10 numbers and I want to index into it? You can actually do that. You can create what we would traditionally call in C or C++ an array. And what PHP does is under the hood, it's still an associative array,
但PHP会让你遍历它。当你请求第1项时，它仍然有效。但在底层，PHP中一切实际上都是映射（map）。它要么是一个原始数字，比如双精度浮点数或字符串，要么是一个映射。在PHP 3中，他们增加了类，这是一种语法糖，但显然非常有用。所以你有带有属性的类等等。
but PHP will let you iterate over it. And when you ask for item one, it still works. But under the hood, everything is effectively a map in PHP. It's either a primitive number, like a double or a string, a primitive variable, like a double or a string, a primitive variable like a double or a string, or it's a map. In PHP 3 they added classes, which is kind of syntactic sugar, but obviously very useful. So you have classes with properties and all of that.
最大的进步来自Facebook。Facebook编写了一种名为Hack的语言。Hack与PHP完全向后兼容。换句话说，你可以拿WordPress这个非常知名的库或工具，在Hack中运行它。所以任何用PHP构建的东西都能在Hack中工作。但你也可以添加一些关键字和更多在Hack中可以做的事情，
The biggest advance came from Facebook. So Facebook wrote a language called Hack. Hack is completely backwards compatible with PHP. So in other words, you can take WordPress, which is a very know, library or tool. You can actually take that and run it in Hack. So anything that's built in PHP will work with Hack. But you can also add, there's some more keywords and some more things you can do in Hack
而在PHP中做不到，这也很酷。另一件事是它可以被编译，所以它不像传统那样被解释，你可以编译它，然后在HHVM虚拟机上运行。这使得代码更快，因为正如我们之前在新闻中讨论的Godbolt和编译器优化。通过进行哪怕一点点编译，你就能获得优化事物、调整内容的能力。这太棒了，因为它允许程序员在不牺牲速度的情况下编写非常可读的代码。是的，完全同意。
that you can't do in PHP, which is pretty cool too. One of the other things is it can be compiled so instead of being interpreted as traditionally you can compile it and then run it on the hhvm virtual machine and that allows the code to be faster because as we were talking about earlier in the one of the news sites was the godbolt and compiler optimizations and how it does that. And so by doing even just a little bit of compilation, you get the ability to kind of optimize things, shift stuff around. And that's awesome because it allows the programmer to still write something that's very readable without sacrificing speed. Yep. Yeah, totally.
深入了解一下Hack添加的一些东西，首先是它增加了类型，这与TypeScript非常相似。你知道你可以拿一个普通的JavaScript文件，重命名为.ts而不是.js，它现在就是TypeScript，运行正常。但一旦你这样做了，并且在使用TypeScript编译器，你现在可以添加“int a = 3”，而不是仅仅“a = 3”，对吧？或者“这个函数接受一个int x和一个float y”，对吧？所以Hack也是一样。你可以随着时间的推移慢慢地向你的代码库添加类型。
So just to kind of dive into some of the things Hack adds, one is it adds types, which is very similar to TypeScript. So you know you can take just a regular JavaScript file and rename it.ts instead of js and it's now TypeScript and it works fine. But once you've done that and you're using the TypeScript compiler, now you can actually go and add like int a equals three, instead of just a equals three, right? Or like this function takes an int x and a float y, right? So hack is the same way. And you can slowly over time add types to your code base.
Hack会理解，如果它没看到类型，那个类型可以是任何东西。但如果它看到了类型，它就可以报出编译器错误。Hack增加了泛型，这非常有用，对吧？如果你想要一个集合数据结构，但你希望它是任何东西的集合，你可以用Hack做到。它的工作方式类似于C++。你写“set”，现在你就拥有了一个字符串集合。
And hack will understand if it doesn't see a type, that that type could be anything. But if it does see a type, it can call out a compiler error. Hack adds generics, which are super useful, right? I mean, if you want a set data structure, but you want it to be a set of anything, you can do that with Hack. And it works similar to C++. You do set, angle bracket, string, angle bracket, and now you have a set of strings.
它有集合。所以你甚至不需要自己写集合。它已经为你做好了。它有set、hash set、hash map。很多你在Java和其他语言中看到的常见集合。它有Lambda函数，现在Java 8也有了。如果你还记得，它们只是作为一等公民的函数。所以我可以说“f = 某个函数”，然后把f传递给另一个函数或另一个对象，那个对象可以持有f并在需要时调用它。它还有异步支持，这非常重要，对吧？
It's got collections. So you don't even have to write the set. It's already done for you. It has set, has hash set, hash map. A lot of these common collections that you'd see in Java and other languages. It has lambda functions which now we have in Java 8. Those are just if you remember they're just functions as first class citizens. So I could say f equals some function and then pass f to another function or another object and that object can hold on to f and call it whenever it wants it also has async support which is super important right
比如你可以调用一个函数，然后传递给它一个回调，它会在返回时执行那个回调。所以这种异步编程模式，我们在Node.js那一期讨论过很多。所以你在问自己，我正在开始一个新项目。我应该使用PHP吗？我不认为它是当下的流行语言，或者说，这听起来太花哨了。它不是那种热门语言，但据我所知，它仍然被广泛使用，即使是用于新项目，因为很多人已经使用它很长时间了。
like if you um you can actually call a function uh and then uh pass it a callback and it'll execute that callback kind of whenever it returns. So just this asynchronous kind of mode of programming, which we talked a lot about in the Node.js episode. So you're asking yourself, I'm starting a new project. Should I use PHP? I don't think it's the language du jour, or I don't, that sounds too fancy pants. It's not the kind of language of the moment. It's not the hot language, but I mean, my understanding, it's still pretty commonly used even for kind of new stuff, because there's a lot of people have been doing it for a long time.
所以他们非常擅长它。他们知道怎么做。它能完成工作。通常这非常重要。但也有很多用PHP编写的遗留代码。所以如果你加入一个有这些代码的项目或团队，你很可能会发现自己在维护PHP代码。但我不会说它是大多数人解决Web问题时的首选。我认为还有很多其他新的JavaScript解决方案，或者服务器端的Node.js
And so they're really good at it. They know how to do it. It gets the job done. And often that's very important. But there's also a lot of legacy stuff written in PHP. And so if you kind of join a project or team that has that, you could very well find yourself maintaining PHP code. But I wouldn't say it's probably the number one choice most people have for the problems on the web. I think there's a lot of other kind of new JavaScript solutions to that or Node.js on the server
来完成一些相同的想法。所以我不会说它在今天被普遍选择，但可能在某些领域确实如此。对于那些一直在使用它的人来说，它显然是一个手头的选择。而且，那些遗留代码不会消失。在上面投入了大量的时间。
to kind of accomplish some of the same ideas. And so I wouldn't say it's commonly chosen today, but there are probably some areas where it is. And for people who have been doing it, I mean, it obviously will be a kind of something at hand for them to choose. And then, you know, that legacy code just doesn't go away. There's a lot of time invested in that.
所以我认为可能还有很多人的时间花在编写PHP上。是的。为了把它放在一个视角下，他们实际上刚刚发布了这个，TIOBE。我不知道我是否应该拼出来，T-I-O-B-E。我不知道我是否应该拼出来，Tiob。但TIOBE指数，他们使用GitHub和一系列其他指标来预测或展示哪种语言最受欢迎。PHP在2016年1月到2017年1月之间从第6位下降到了第10位。
And so I would say there's still probably a lot of people's days are spent still writing in PHP. Yep. So just to, like, put it in perspective, so they actually just released this, the T-I-O-B-E. I don't know if I'm supposed to spell that out or not, T-O-B-E. I don't know if I'm supposed to spell that out or not, Tiob. But the Tiob index, sort of, they use GitHub and a bunch of other metrics to try to predict or to demonstrate sort of which language is the most popular. And PHP dropped from 6th to 10th between January 2016 and January 2017.
所以我认为可能还是有很多人每天都在用PHP编写代码。是的。为了说明一下，他们刚刚发布了TIOBE指数，我不知道该不该把它拼出来，T-I-O-B-E。我不知道该不该把它拼出来，Tiob。但TIOBE指数，他们使用GitHub和其他一些指标来尝试预测或展示哪种语言最受欢迎。在2016年1月到2017年1月之间，PHP从第6位下降到了第10位。
And I think a lot of that is just because, you know, a combination of Python, Node.js, and some of these other languages are just kind of, you know, picking up more steam. But, I mean, the fact that it's 10th is still very powerful. I mean, as Patrick said, there's tons of people using it. But also, I think measures like that, I'm not familiar with that exact one and the methodology. But I think measures like that where you're kind of looking on GitHub and stuff, that's probably a lot of new public development. But, you know, a lot of lines of code get written in legacy systems, not just maintenance, but new features being added. And so, you know, I think those metrics probably skew to new starts. Like there's a weighting to the languages that new projects are started in.
我认为很大程度上是因为，你知道，Python、Node.js 和其他一些语言的组合正在变得越来越流行。但是，我的意思是，它能排在第 10 位仍然非常厉害。正如 Patrick 所说，有大量的人在使用它。但我也认为，像这样的衡量标准——我不熟悉具体的衡量标准和方法——但我觉得像这种在 GitHub 上查看之类的衡量标准，可能更多反映的是新的公共开发项目。然而，你知道，大量的代码是在遗留系统中编写的，不仅仅是维护，还有新功能的添加。所以，我认为这些指标可能偏向于新项目。就像对新项目所使用的语言有一种加权一样。
Yeah, yeah, it's a really good point. Yeah, I mean, PHP is just insanely popular. So where is PHP used? Wow, so many apps, especially open source apps, are built in PHP. You know, WordPress is probably the most common. PHP BB, which is a forum. The reason why it's BB, it's from the the phrase bulletin board right um did you ever go on bulletin boards no oh yeah me neither i have friends who have like like really awesome stories
是的，确实，这是一个非常好的观点。我的意思是，PHP 简直太受欢迎了。那么 PHP 用在哪里呢？哇，太多的应用程序，尤其是开源应用程序，都是用 PHP 构建的。你知道，WordPress 可能是最常见的。PHPBB，这是一个论坛。之所以叫 BB，是因为它来自“公告栏”（bulletin board）这个短语。嗯，你以前上过公告栏吗？没有。哦，我也是。我没有朋友有那种非常棒的故事。
about things they did on bulletin boards like rpgs that they played using message passing but i think i should invent a past history where I did. So you could regale us with your bulletin board stories. When I was a kid. Back in my day, we passed punch cards back and forth. PHP My Admin. If you have a MySQL instance, this is the web interface to that that's extremely popular. I've used all of these. Gallery, Drupal, MediaWiki, like Wikipedia itself is all written in PHP and is open source.
关于他们在公告栏上做的事情，比如他们使用消息传递玩角色扮演游戏（RPG）。但我认为我应该编造一段我曾经参与过的过去，这样你就可以用你的公告栏故事来款待我们了。当我还是个孩子的时候。在我的那个年代，我们来回传递打孔卡。PHPMyAdmin。如果你有一个 MySQL 实例，这就是它的 Web 界面，非常流行。这些我都用过。Gallery、Drupal、MediaWiki，比如维基百科本身就是用 PHP 编写的，而且是开源的。
Joomla, which is a super popular content management system. So just a ton of really powerful apps have been written in PHP. And they're so extensible. People have written so many. It's almost like Emacs or VI, right? People have written so many extensions to these apps that it's just very hard to make them obsolete. And I'm sure they'll be around for the next 10 years. So yeah, so that's PHP in a nutshell.
Joomla，这是一个非常流行的内容管理系统。所以，大量的强大应用程序都是用 PHP 编写的。而且它们的可扩展性非常强。人们编写了太多扩展。这几乎就像 Emacs 或 VI，对吧？人们为这些应用程序编写了如此多的扩展，以至于很难让它们过时。我相信它们在未来 10 年内还会存在。所以，这就是 PHP 的简要概述。
I mean, as Patrick said, I also wouldn't really recommend using it for a new project. I think Node.js, Python, these other ones are kind of, even like Ruby to a lesser extent, are kind of, even like Ruby to a lesser extent, are kind of making PHP obsolete. But it's still important language to learn. If you're looking for a job, there's a good chance, you know, there'll be some PHP involved. And yeah, and let us know what you think. If you've built anything amazing in PHPp that you have on github or somewhere else let us know and we'll we'll uh we'll talk about on that show so to wrap it up we'll repeat the
我的意思是，正如 Patrick 所说，我也不太建议在新项目中使用它。我认为 Node.js、Python 以及其他一些语言，甚至在某种程度上包括 Ruby，都在让 PHP 逐渐过时。但它仍然是一门值得学习的重要语言。如果你正在找工作，很有可能你会接触到一些 PHP。是的，让我们知道你的想法。如果你用 PHP 构建了什么了不起的东西，并且放在 GitHub 或其他地方，请告诉我们，我们会在节目中讨论它。为了总结一下，我们将重复我们在节目中间提到的工具和书籍，这样你可以很容易地跳转到这一部分。那两本书是《自私的基因》和《Abedin Gate》。然后 Jason 推荐了 Emacs Org Mode 作为节目工具。我推荐了 Linters。我不知道说我推荐 Linters 是否真的有帮助。不，我认为人们应该使用 Linters。好吧，不，我认为 Linters 实际上是一个很棒的工具，因为它需要一点工作，很多人不想投入时间——包括我自己——不想花时间把它集成到工作流程中，但之后我们总是很高兴我们这样做了。所以希望我们可以传递这种知识。Linters 绝对有用，我的意思是最后重复一遍 Linters 是为了让人们去查找。
kind of tools and books we mentioned in the middle of the show so that this is easily you can scrub to this part easily uh and that was the the selfish gene abedin Gate. Those were the two books. And then Jason recommended Emacs Org Mode as a tool of the show. And I recommended Linters. I don't know that that's really actually helpful to say I recommended Linters. No, I think, you know, people should use Linters. Well, no, I think Linters is actually a great tool because it's one of these things that it takes a little bit of work and a lot of people don't want to put in myself included don't really want to put in the time to uh to integrate it into your workflow but then we're always so glad we did and so hopefully we can pass that yeah of knowledge linters are definitely useful i meant repeating linters at the end for people to look up
哦，好的，抱歉，没关系。没关系。那太棒了。但感谢大家，感谢我们所有的听众一直支持我们。Jason 和我刚才还在互相讲述以前播客里的往事。哇，那听起来太棒了。
oh all right sorry never mind Never mind. That's awesome. But thanks, everyone, for all our listeners and sticking with us. Jason and I were just regaling each other with stories of yore from the podcast of old. Wow, that sounded awesome.
我们做这个已经有一段时间了，但我们很享受，而且我们总是很高兴听到听众朋友们的声音。是的，有一件事，如果有人买了 T 恤，你知道，我买了一件 T 恤，只是为了确保它不会……
And we've been doing this a while, but we enjoy it and we always enjoy hearing from everyone out there in listener land. Yeah, one thing, if someone bought a t-shirt, you know, so I bought a t-shirt, uh, uh, you know, just to make sure that the, it wasn't going to be,
你知道，确保它的质量很好之类的。嗯，我觉得它很好。我的意思是，我喜欢它。我有时会穿着它去上班，这太俗气了。不，我知道，我知道，自我推销，我知道这有点俗气。但如果你买了衬衫——我知道有几个人买了衬衫，实际上很多人买了衬衫——如果你买了，请告诉我，给我们发封电子邮件。如果你觉得标志太大或太小，或者你觉得 T 恤很棒，请告诉我们你的想法。你知道，T 恤仍然是节目中比较新的部分，所以我们正在寻求你的反馈。是的，我的意思是，我想我们不需要知道，因为如果你买了我们已经知道了，但哦，是的，不要只是告诉我们你买了，而是发送
you know, that it was going to be good quality and all of that. Um, uh, and I, I feel like it's, it's good. I mean, I like it. Uh, I wear it to work sometimes, which is super cheesy what no i know i know self-promotion i know it's kind of cheesy but uh uh but no if if you bought a shirt i know a few people have bought a shirt uh actually many people have bought a shirt um and if you have let me know send us an email uh if you think the logo is too big too small if you think t-shirt's amazing let us know what you think um you know the t-shirt is still a rather new part of the show and so uh we're looking for your feedback yeah i mean i guess we don't need to know we already know if you buy it because we know but oh yeah don't just tell us you bought it yeah but send
给我们一张照片，或者加上我们的标签，或者在推特上艾特我们，或者现在酷孩子们做的任何事情，关于你穿着它在某个很酷的地方的照片，那会很棒。哦，那是个好主意。是的，如果你穿着这件衬衫在任何地方，但如果是在大峡谷之类的地方，那会更史诗。等等，为什么是大峡谷？因为那和我们的节目没什么关系。我觉得穿着它去计算机历史博物馆，或者穿着它站在你很棒的 vi 主题编辑器前，或者其他什么东西，那才对。是的，你是完全正确的，它需要是你喜欢的东西，比如站在理查德·斯托曼的蜡像旁边之类的。如果你有那张照片或任何穿着你的
us like a picture or hashtag us or tweet us or whatever the cool kids do these days about um you know a picture of you wearing it somewhere cool that would be awesome oh that's a great idea yeah if you uh have yourself wearing this shirt anywhere uh but if it's on like the grand canyon or something that'd be even more epic wait why the grand canyon because that's like nothing to do with our show i feel like wearing it to a computer history museum or wearing it in front of your awesome you know vi themed editor or you know whatever something yeah yeah you're totally right yeah it needs to be like something you like would next to a wax statue of richard stallman or something um If you have that picture or any others wearing your
T 恤的照片，请发布出来并艾特 programming throwdown，或者如果是 Twitter，就艾特 neural nets for life。我们会转发你，分享你，并让你感到尴尬
t-shirt, post it and do at programming throwdown or in the case of Twitter, at neural nets for life. We will retweet you and reshare you and embarrass you
如果你希望我们这样做的话。不，我们不会让你尴尬。如果你让自己尴尬的话。不，我们不会让你尴尬。如果你让自己尴尬，我们只会荣幸地宣传它。那是真的。我们会放大你的尴尬。那实际上会很酷。这是一个好主意。无论如何，让我们知道你对衬衫的看法。
if you want us to. No, we won't embarrass you. If you embarrass yourself,. No, we won't embarrass you. If you embarrass yourself, we'll just do the honor of promoting that. That's true. We'll amplify your embarrassment. That'd be really cool, actually. It's a great idea. Either way, let us know what you think of the shirts.
好的，下次见。回头见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。回头见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Alright, until next time. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. See you later. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.